I'm hiding in the guest room you guys
I'm hiding in the guest room because my
kids called out Kim kardashian-west is
just trying to get some alone time in
quarantine Lauren can I please just do
my little tutorial it's all I want to do
is one little fun thing for myself the
mom of four wanted to do a k'kaw makeup
tutorial from her guest bathroom but it
didn't go uninterrupted by her
six-year-old last week Kim and Kanye
certainly had their hands full during
isolation with their kids North
saint-jacques hago and Psalm let me say
being at home with four kids if I ever
for a minute than I wanted another one
last week in a video chat on the view
Kim joked quarantine sealed the deal on
having no more kids I've been doing
laundry and cooking and we're now I mean
the kids just got on spring break
thank God being their teacher to my
newfound respect of her teacher they
deserve so much it's just it's been
tough juggling at all speaking of tough
the Keeping Up with the Kardashians
showdown has kept us entertained and
inspired some fantastic parodies
I'm so proud of my girls but this one
from comedian Benito Skinner caught the
attention of Kim Kourtney and khloé
Mason get off live Mason it's just like
I told Sophia you can't get an Instagram
until you turn 13 Kim commented oh my
god this is the best Chloe wrote I love
you and Kourtney chimed in with Kendall
would it kill you to put on some makeup
I just literally don't even want to do
it the Liam Kourtney doesn't even want
to do the lamb
[Music]